this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is going to be
taking a look at some more firearms from
cyberpunk 2077 some of which
really made him laugh selected mode
stone cold killer
happy slaughtering what's that
wow i don't know what to say about that
i kind of like it
if there are any other games going to
mechanics you guys want to see jordan
break down let us know in the comment
section below and make sure to subscribe
as well as we've got tons of content
just like this on the channel including
loadout a show where we take a look at
the history and impact of some of the
most iconic weapons in gaming right
let's take a look at the guns of
cyberpunk 2077
well i expected wacky from cyberpunk and
i'm not disappointed in that respect my
first impression is of a sci-fi desert
eagle type thing and we can see
explosions taking place in the breach
yeah there's this fire in the chamber
now if you see fire from the chamber of
your conventional firearms something's
gone horribly wrong so i think these
must be rocket projectiles or rocket
assisted or something we've also got a
really bizarre under-barrel type
attachment we do see a periodic attempt
to attach accessories other than lights
and lasers to pistol rails like bayonets
for example anyway this one is a flame
thrower of some kind a tiny flamethrower
which i think might be the only pistol
accessory i've never seen attempted in
real life the sights on this thing are
really conventional we've got uh glock
style white trough at the back and a
white dot on the front very 20th century
iron sights on this high tech albeit
kind of parallel universe from what i
understand
weapon does look quite cool it's got a
magazine in front of the pistol grip
rather than in it i guess the advantage
there is these projectiles look very
long so you wouldn't fit those in the
grip of the weapon so you need a
magazine i don't know either hanging off
the back of the pistol which would be
like it wouldn't be great or where it is
makes the whole weapon longer than it
needs to be you have to put the barrel
in front of the magazine the magazine in
front of the pistol grip it all makes
for a very long gun
[Applause]
quite an interesting looking gun i'm
getting some stereo aug vibes from it a
lot of sort of detail nice detail on it
i'm not sure all of it's tremendously
functional but then hey i don't know how
this thing works reciprocating cocking
handles which are generally frowned upon
at the moment and probably always will
be albeit they are up and out of the way
of the shooter so it wouldn't actually
be a problem the magazine release is a
bit weird it looks like pretty sure it's
almost like an electronic system you
press the button on the front edge of
the magazine well and then pull the
magazine out not really very efficient
when we already have magazines that drop
free when you press a mechanical button
this would be a sort of backwards step
[Music]
okay bit of um detail that that works
here we've got the classic computer game
movie
quad muzzle flash thing going on uh
which is you know always looks nice
doesn't always make a huge amount of
sense here though the muzzle device does
appear to have the ports in it that
match where that muzzle flare is is
emanating from so whilst you don't want
a firearm that produces ludicrous muzzle
flash that is distracting slash blinding
in low light conditions slash gives you
away to the enemy at least this makes
some sort of mechanical sense
no no no
so i'm gonna dub this the angry bees gun
because uh it's it's essentially a
really sci-fi up mad max shotgun but the
the sort of nine volt battery looking
ammunition
units feed things whatever they are
cartridges i suppose are
multiple round and they're all firing a
sort of swarm of shots that seem to fly
almost at random so there's clearly some
technology going on here that i'm not
privy to
we had a really
a nice demonstration of this thing's
capabilities there where the player
character is behind cover and backs off
around it and shoots at whatever your i
brain hud has previously locked onto and
the whole swarm of shot go round the
corner like cartoon bullets from a
warner brothers cartoon and kill the guy
i definitely applaud things that not
only look different and fun and cool but
actually have different functionality
you know we can all do a space assault
rifle or a space shotgun but in terms of
functionality and gameplay you wanted to
do something different oh gentle gentle
cylinder stroke there
it's a very cool looking revolver it is
reminiscent of well the front end is uh
chiappa rhino the overall appearance
though is a bit more mataba auto
revolver now normally um i can't show
you the classical material that everyone
knows that looks really cool and
presumably inspired the kiapa as well
because we haven't got one however
the mataba we've got
is actually quite a bit more reminiscent
of the one in cyberpunk because it has
the cylinder
in front of
the trigger it's not a perfect match by
any means but it yeah really has a i
mean this this this thing looks
cyberpunk on its own i think
weird kind of polymer pistol grip on the
back of the of the game gun obviously
not on this in this case this is a
target revolver as you can see so this
model less familiar perhaps to most
people is the mtr-6 this is a 38 special
it has a catch here for the cylinder
pull down and then push out the cylinder
and it works pretty much by default
with
its own proprietary form of clip and you
drop that in
these are inert rounds by the way swing
the cylinder up into place and that's
that's your loading mechanism so even
the loading of this feels quite quite
cyberpunk and it's vaguely reminiscent
of what i'm seeing here which is the
only gun i think that we have that
really looks anything like what's in
cyberpunk
a much more conventional looking pistol
here this is something that we could
make now in fact someone did it was
called the hudson h9 and this how this
is by no means a copy of that but it it
i would hazard a guess that the designer
of this referenced the hudson h9 there's
a there's a circular feature on the side
of this below the slide above the
trigger guard it's very reminiscent of
what's on the h9 the general
configuration of it yeah that would be
my guess there's not much i would rule
out for near future when it comes down
to handguns except that i would expect
to see a red dot sight on each and every
one of them from about
let's let's let's be cautious and say 20
years i would expect all full-size
pistols at least
to have some sort of a red dot sight on
them
no more iron sights well maybe not no
more iron sights but yeah red dot is the
future
[Music]
now having having gone on about red dot
the lack of red dot sights on this
pistol knowing full well that there
would be some we've got one and it's an
interesting one as well it looks to be a
miniature
well it's it's a reflex sight projected
from a base which is what i keep
anticipating the future does hold for us
is some sort of low profile base that
emits a little holographic
reticle so there's nothing to get hit in
terms of field of view you would you
would be looking a little bit further
over the top of your pistol and you have
unlimited field of view because there's
no
framing disturbing you're blocking your
view if you think about uh red dot
sights uh like sitting in the car you're
driving a car with pillars and a roof
and a dashboard well ideally for visit
full visibility you wouldn't have any
pillars or roof
but we need that for safety reasons with
a pistol or any firearm you need the
framing to protect the sensitive bits of
glass in future we probably won't need
that and that's kind of what we're
seeing
this one is what they what they called
down south i believe a bit larry very
brightly colored and the the sort of
receiver architecture is
a bit bonkers we've got a very robust
looking overarching rail that well i
suppose it would work a bit like a
carrying handle but has the error of a
girder about it this is something that
might we might see more of we're already
starting to see remote controls as it
were on on firearms i suppose starting
with the bullpup trigger where there's a
bar connecting the trigger to the seer
and then
rifles like the x95 where the magazine
release is remotely connected albeit
mechanically to the magazine release at
the back of the weapon if battery and
wireless technology were to get
sufficiently reliable there's no reason
why your controls couldn't be
wherever you want them to be and
with some sort of tactile feedback
because you know a touchscreen style
affair wouldn't really work but the
point is we might just about see
electronic controls uh maybe you know
electronic ignition we've had that
experimented with with small arms and
it's routinely used in artillery and
then our controls could be almost
anywhere you know servo motors inside
the gun you press a button the thing
[ __ ] itself
maybe i think we're a long way off that
though
that is
deeply ugly that's got to be
i don't know it's like it's a sort of
clam shell
polymer receiver with all sorts of
angles and curves that don't belong yeah
it looks like someone's left a p90 in
the sun for too long struggling to make
sense of it let's let's watch some more
i believe i could see the words budget
arms on this thing which actually rings
pretty true looking at it that general
configuration is bizarre there's a the
magazine is sitting at a really unhappy
angle in terms of angle of presentation
to actually feed rounds into the chamber
and it does appear to be a conventional
well i don't know how it's operated but
a conventional cartridge firearm at
least and there's something going on at
the back there that almost seems to be
the like the p90s weird front curved
grip only it's the rear grip i haven't
had a good view of it but it has a sort
of high-tech looking uh scope on it with
a lot of tiny text for you to read which
is helpful in the middle of the fire
fights i can't work out what most of the
tiny text says but um we have a round
counter makes a certain amount of sense
it's not too obtrusive handy to have
that information what's less handy when
your guns just run out of ammunition is
the word reloading in block capitals
making it harder to see the person that
might be shooting at you when you've
literally just run out of ammunition
that seems like
a poor move to know i think this i think
this thing is growing on me slightly as
something that makes sense in this world
as the cheapest possible automatic
weapon you can get your hands on it's
called budget arms it looks cheaply made
i assume it's taking advantage of
current era manufacturing techniques
there doesn't look to be a way to
replace the optical sight it's just it's
integral intriguingly it does take a a
suppressor i'd almost expect any
futuristic firearm to accept a
suppressor but if this thing is as cheap
as it appears to be i'm kind of
surprised that it does
a bullpup pistol actual ballpark pistols
are from memory non-existent this is
genuinely a bullpup in that it has
that breach that firing mechanism
well behind not only the trigger but the
pistol grip as well making it very
compact indeed also a bit on we already
looking at this thing though it's got a
lot of mass at the back and off to one
side as well because of this unusual
reloading system but i give i give the
designers some credit here for a very
interesting looking gun and a new feed
system how plausible it would be
probably not very but it does look good
they're almost like miniature lewis gun
pans or something you slap them in the
side and then there's a very a very cool
looking reload where the character
swipes out the empty magazine drum
whatever cylinder really out of the out
of the gun and then pushes the fresh one
home all looks great
i don't really quite get how it fires if
these are conventional rounds they're
coming in at a ridiculous angle clearly
don't feed they fire from within the
cylinder there's there are flashes of
electrical blue energy going on here and
what's flying out of the side of the gun
are not cartridge cases in a
conventional sense they look almost like
machine gun link so i don't know what
those are or how those would fly out of
the gun maybe something is getting
chambered from this maybe it's not a
cylinder maybe it's a drum i quite like
things that i can't figure out when they
look like they might work
it's it's well you know if you think too
hard about it it probably won't work
this i give that i give the sort of
sci-fi pass now the sights on this thing
really ought to be the sights on
everything in this game because they're
nice and low profile and they look like
they can be used as iron sights in a
pinch because there is a there is a
notch in the center of that rear base
but by default the rear sight projects
an aiming reticle and that's all you
would need the only reason we don't have
this now is that battery technology
isn't good enough well and also i
suppose
emitted optics would be subject to
ambient light conditions that would make
them very hard to see so we are a way
off from that to be fair but it's what i
like to see in a science fiction game
selected mode
stone cold killer
happy slaughtering
what's that
wow
i don't know what to say about that i
kind of like it
it it seems like something you'd get in
a fifth element sequel
yeah crossed with um something like uh
mr dna from jurassic park which is based
on old you know 40s 50s
training films and public information
films with animated characters in them
of course it's a talking bullet that
wears shades uh apart from skippy
himself the gun looks kind of
understandably normal it's sort of a low
profile self-loading pistol i assume it
uses conventional ish ammunition but
it's got some kind of smart targeting
capability that i imagine i'm about to
see the results of
[Music]
error
premature discharge i'm sorry this never
happens
of course right i should learn to uh
watch the whole thing before commenting
because this is not at all conventional
it doesn't have a slide doesn't have a
bolt doesn't seem to reject any
cartridge cases so i'm guessing it's
caseless and has some tiny microscopic
internal bolt it also produces its own
negligent discharges as a sort of meta
plot point which is i think is genius
okay i've just noticed that there's
something reciprocating at the front of
the gun i'm trying to remain
professional and focused here despite
the uh amusement factor so there is
there's something cycling here there's
something
chambering locking firing uh god knows
how and a load of other ai electronic
gubbins a possibly final footnote on
this one is that we appear to have
ambidextrous slide release controls on
this only there isn't a slide and they
don't appear to do anything i think they
were probably modeled as
pinch-to-release catches for the
magazine which is quite reminiscent of
the p90 in the way that it comes in from
the rear and is horizontal and
presumably well this feeds from the
front rather than the p90 mag which
feeds from the rear but probably the
inspiration for this but yeah those
controls don't seem to do anything the
magazine secures itself and is just
pulled off the gun
when it's empty but far be it for me to
criticize skippy
right i think i understand the
autonomous aiming thing now so the gun
isn't aiming at all it's the projectiles
that are being guided so like like at
least one of the other guns in the game
you fire them conventionally or the gun
fires itself in this case when the mood
takes it and then the projectiles are
guided to the part to the target or in
this case the part of the target
specifically that the ai is able
to target really fascinating concept
even if it was done done seriously but
instead we have the sort of borderlands
level humor uh which i
i cannot help laughing at the the fun
facts especially are uh are really
well fun
okay i like this one this is
reflective of the old
50s 60s 70s attempts to fire more than
one shot from a from a military rifle at
once the idea being to create to
increase hit probability and assuming
you hit them potentially lethality as
well because they'll get hit by more
than one shot essentially the advantage
of a shotgun but fired from a rifle and
the simplest way to achieve that was to
put two or three bullets in the same
case then there were multiple barrel
options for it and that appears to be
what we have here so we have i think
three barrels and the outer two
pivot away almost like swing wings on a
fighter jet so that when you're firing
normally you get a spread of shot and
then when you aim those close up and the
barrels they will then converge uh more
on the same spot it's it's all sci-fi of
course but it makes some sense you know
it's just not just creating the effect
out of nowhere something is happening
that is logically associated with the
effect you're getting not every game gun
works that way
if you'd like to support what we do here
at the royal armouries we have a link as
ever in the description for donations or
membership um you can of course come and
visit one of our three sites if you're
here in the uk and we also have our own
youtube channel and various social media
outlets that you can check out as well
but again thank you for watching we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you